[Musique]
le maître mot de cette rentrée 2001
ergonomie cette année c'est en effet le
confort des écoliers qui est à l'honneur
avec des stylos munis de systèmes anti
dérapant anti fatigue ou anti douleur
quand on prend le stylo il ya un petit
genre de gomme là ça fait mal
les classeurs eux aussi sont désormais
profil et sans parler du cartable
attendant c'est au cartable et
ergonomique entre eux dont celui ci par
exemple on le voyait derrière il
une rigidité plus importante que sur les
anciens cartable on a tous connu un
système de strache d un système hambourg
et des petits cousins en bas et un
système antichoc en dessous l'autre
grande tendance des marchés le cartable
à roulettes demander parfois par les
enseignants mais qui n'a pas entièrement
conquis les familles le sac n'a pas tenu
plus d'une année parce qu'ils se sont
amusés à se tirer sur le sac donc bruno
d'année le sac qu'il a été garanti
trentenaire donc j'espère un quart au
printemps il a terminé ses études eh
bien il le sac il n'a pas duré plus que
j'aime pas du tout les formes unis les
mêmes les couleurs c'est trop fluo trop
carré j'aime pas car pour les élèves la
tendance est plutôt à la sobriété
agrémenté de gadgets indispensables la
colle fluo qui se voit dans le noir ou
encore le lion ce stylo design à encre
gel
vous avez le petit gadget qui plaît
beaucoup aux enfants un tout petit peu
moins aux parents c'est la hausse pour
téléphones portables donc ça commence
très tôt maintenant
alors on fait un gadget un peu plus pour
les parents ça change donc c'est le
rubik's cube qui nous sert à réviser nos
tables de multiplication de façon un peu
ludique quant au compagnon de la rentrée
les pokémon et autres digimon n'ont plus
la cote la mode est aux d'idole cette
délicieuse petite souris qui dévore le
marché
des couleurs vives des logos
identifiable des personnages et même des
peluches
stylos aux classeurs les produits de
marque ont envahi les rayons pour la
rentrée des fournitures sur mesure pour
les enfants comme morgan à 8 ans alain
pons déjà ses choix trousses et sacs
siglés obligatoires
un parc
c'est un jeu bien sûr de moi surtout à
des
pressions des copains mais aussi
pression commerciale
un exemple cette année harry potter le
petit sorcier fait sa première rentrée
les enfants ont aimé le livre ils
achèteront la trousse 59 france est
quand même plus de six fois le montant
d'un article 1er prix pas étonnant que
les produits des marques soit mise en
valeur pour le classent plutôt à
l'entrée du magasin on les met ensemble
et on essaye de rendre les produits et
bien accessible ici rien n'est laissé au
hasard le magasin applique des règles
simples mais efficaces c'est un
emplacement stratégique puisque c'est le
sait le mural et il est extrêmement
colorés donc la cliente parce qu'elle
est dans l'allée le voit et va vers son
univers un dispositif implacable qui ne
fonctionnerait pas si ces jeunes
consommateurs n'avaient pas intégré une
donnée capitale
les enfants sont très conscients en fait
du niveau de prix que leurs parents sont
prêts à mettre tous peuvent m attention
les marques s'attaque même où tout petit
et à trois ans un enfant sait très bien
comment faire flancher ses parents
à voir le soin qu'elle met pour le
choisir pas de doute possible objets
star de la rentrée c'est bien lui c'est
le cartable 40 cm de large en moyenne de
29 à 500 francs et pour le choisir il
faut
soit un peu mode ou
un peu mode pour la rentrée 2001 cela
signifie essentiellement sac à dos
tendance colorait mais attention fois
deux mères de famille l'abus de mode
nuit sérieusement à l'écolier
il est très très mode au risque de se le
faire piquer donc on choisit on choisit
ont choisi exactement comme dans les
années 60-70 confortable spacieux
pratique et surtout capable d'engranger
six à huit kilos de livres et de cahiers
tous les jours mais le bon vieux
cartable en cuir de papa maman a
sérieusement pris du plomb dans l aile
parole d'experte
[Musique]
en 98 99 et 2000 fini les problèmes de
poids sur le dos des bambins grâce au
cartable cabas à roulettes
mais depuis le look mamie fait ses
courses a fait long feu m'attabler est à
moi sur ce que les enfants auront
d'avoir à l'école et depuis quelques
temps le nec plus ultra n'est plus tant
dans la mode mais dans l'électronique le
cartable futuriste remplacent les
kilogrammes par des ko seul problème on
paie toujours en qu'il offrons 10 à
15000 francs pièce même en euros ça fait
trop
[Musique]